hi guys it's Jonah here this is a video
request from those of you who are
actually struggling to put on weight it
might sound crazy to those of you who is
trying to lose weight but there are
people who no matter how much they eat
they just can't seem to put on weight so
facts putting on weight is actually much
harder than losing weight so you can
lose between 1 to 2 pounds per week but
to put on weight to put on clean weights
you are looking at between 1 to 2 pounds
per month to put on weight the concept
is similar to losing weight so you need
to consume a lot more than what your
body burns for instance if your body
were to build between 1,400 to 1,500
calories per day you need to consume at
least 2,000 to 2,500 calories per day
it's not easy to consume a large amount
of food therefore I want to share with
you some tips to help you to put on
weight the first tip is to consume food
with high calorie so therefore your diet
needs to consist with a lot of healthy
fats because they are high in calories
and a lot of natural sugar as well which
is also high in calories so whenever
you're cooking a meal always add a good
amount of olive oil in it to increase
the calories intake use food and consume
food that is high in calories for
example avocado peanut butter they're
really high in calories and they're
healthy as well nuts high in calories
really healthy as well so the first tip
is to consume food ice pack with high
calories and consume them in larger
quantities that way you are already
increasing your calories intake per day
the second tip is to add omega-3 fatty
acid into your food there are a lot of
positive reviews in regards to omega-3
fatty acid it especially helps women to
reset your body chemistry which helps
you to put on weight quicker therefore
try to consume
lots of fish because they are packed
with omega-3 bins and leafy vegetables
those are food that is rich with omega-3
so add them into your diet as much as
you can and as often as you can
the third tip is to drink a lot of milk
at least two to four times a day
forget about the semi skimmed milk just
go for the full fat milk milk has been
said to be able to identify if you're
underweight and you will help you to
gain weight faster and easier therefore
if you want to gain weight try to have a
cup of milk with every meal hence people
who is trying to lose weight need to
reduce their milk intake all-to-all for
semi skimmed milk tip number four is to
eat more frequently at least five to six
times a day and to have lots of healthy
carbs in your meals so good carbs like
potatoes whole-wheat bread pasta and
rice should be eaten at least four times
a day and also pack lots of vegetables
and fruits in your meal because fruits
and vegetables contains carbs as well so
instead of eating the whole fruits as it
is you can always blend lots of fruits
up and make a huge cup of smoothie for
your breakfast so try to have one
smoothie a day and at least have
formulas in a day which contains high
carbs another good way to increase the
calorie intake is through supplements so
you can choose to have protein shakes to
add on your calories per day but do
remember that the protein shakes you're
having should not be replaced as a meal
it is an adult supplement to help you to
increase the calories intake you should
still have your five to six meals a day
which is packed full of carbs and full
of fresh fruits and vegetables and the
last tip is to exercise if you can
commit to at least working out three to
four times a week for a minimum of
thirty minutes you will notice a
difference in comparison to people who's
trying to lose weight you need to do
minimal cardio and lots of strength
training so try to keep your cardio to
warmups and your cooldowns and try to
focus on good quality strength training
what I mean by that is to use heavy
weights as part of your training so
instead of doing using light weights
where you'll be able to do 50
to 20 reps you should be using heavy
weights and you should only be able to
do eight to ten reps so if you can do
more than ten reps
you need to increase your waves that is
the way to build nests and to build
muscle so get a workout body if you can
will support you when you're working out
and remember to allow your muscles to
rest try not to work on the same muscles
every day your muscles need at least 24
to 48 hours to recover so for instance
Monday can be legs day Tuesday can be
shoulders and arms Wednesday can be your
chest and back and then repeat the whole
sequence again on Thursday Friday and
Saturday remember putting on weight is
much harder than losing weight but if
you have a good meal plan and a good
workout plan it is not impossible you
will be looking at one to two pounds per
month so start now feed your body with
lots of good food good carbs good
protein good fats and have a good
quality strength training at least three
to four times a week please do like this
video share this video to follow me on
Facebook and Instagram because that's
where I'll update myself daily and
please do subscribe to my youtube
channel for more fitness and nutritional
videos
you